I just completed a web page and video series on the Greek minuscule script
sounded medieval documents stating from about 88 shifty to 1850 I realized that
some of my readers and viewers might wish to examine primary manuscripts for
yourselves.
Fortunately,
the British libraries digitized collection allows you to do just that from your
own computer,
up close and for free,
and the collection isn't limited to Greek texts either.
Yeah.
In this video,
I'm going to walk you through the basic features of their manuscript fewer.
I'll also offer some tips to help you get the most out of your copy practice if
you're learning these scripts as part of your language or calligraphy studies.
If you've had enough of me and just want to browse the collection and jumped
into viewing manuscripts,
here's the web address.
I'll also put it down in the inflow bar below.
When you visit their page,
you can browse manuscripts or search for a specific document.
Once you've clicked on a manuscript in his profile page,
you'll get a new tab with the manuscript viewer.
The top shows,
the manuscript title and content description.
A few key things to look for.
Here are the original author,
the work,
the year or date range,
and the manuscript number.
Below that,
the main body of the page is taken up by the viewer.
You'll see some handy controls on the upper right above the image and on the
upper left of the image itself.
The controls on the left allow you to zoom in and out,
reset your view.
Veal full screen or toggle show where height controls the dropdown lists and
arrows on the top right help you navigate through the entire manuscript.
The select list next to view lets you choose between viewing a single page open
book view with even pages on the left and odd pages on the right or folio view
with odd pages on the left and even pages on the ride.
Finally,
you'll need a bit more knowledge to navigate using page numbers.
Lowercase f stands for folio.
Our means recto or the front of a page vias verse so or the back of a page.
Each page number then refers to a whole leaf,
not just to one side of a sheet.
Also noticed the British library copyright on the bottom of the image.
Although the text of these manuscripts may be in the public domain,
the images themselves may have a different status.
Well that's good to get you started.
I hope you have fun as he reached into the past and explore some amazing
manuscript treasures,
some helpful tips if you will be doing copy practice in order to learn to write
in these hands.
I have a few hard one recommendations from my many hours of practice.
Yeah,
right in a well lit area.
Adopt good posture,
relax your eyes every once in awhile.
Copying can be strenuous,
especially when you're new and paying close attention to small details.
Zoom in on the text to see clearly.
This allows you to distinguish writing strokes and lifts of the pen.
Move from the basic to the tough.
Start with clear,
legible hands rather than challenging examples.
For example,
for students of the Greek miniscule hands,
I recommend learning the standard printed miniscule characters.
Then neat medieval minuscule documents.
Before you tackle examples like this,
look for words you recognize.
It's like decoding a puzzle.
You start with known values rather than the unknown.
Work with physical copies whenever possible.
This will go further in protecting your eyes,
since you may find yourself staring at a computer screen for hours on end to
imitate even brief texts and finer hands.
Of course,
avoid doing anything that will violate fair use.
Finally,
enjoy your pursuit as you participate in a long history of scrabbled tradition.
This is a wonderful and direct way to learn some visually stunning scripts.
As always,
thanks for taking the time to learn with me.
MMM.